hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was suggested to me
via email uh by a user
by an excellent subscriber writer named
eric flair uh so thank you for that uh
it's uh it's a three minute blitz game
three plus so
uh between national master nelson lopez
and a user that goes by the name of
reynold peligros
and he said that it reminded him of the
immortal game or rather the
the mortal evergreen game because
there's an immortal game in the
evergreen game but
both of them are considered immortal
games but the evergreen game
uh played of course between magnus
carlsen and max deutsch but in reality
i'm sure as you've all realized that
even if not you know
right from the start between uh out of
anderson and uh
john dufresne in 1852 in berlin uh but
as
i i don't think it's quite up to that
standard but it is a
quite a very nice game so uh we will
show it and before we check out the game
i would just like to say that today
there's a uh team leeches arena
so if you guys want to be part of the
team uh the first link in the
description below will take you to the
uh where you can sign up for the
tournament so uh while all of you can
play
uh only those who score the most points
will count so
only 20 people who score the most points
i will uh go into the into the final
count but it doesn't really matter
because you don't know how much uh you
know
anyone else will score i will be
streaming it uh
so there's a there's a chance that your
game will be showcased on today's stream
uh so that being said let's check out
the game uh as uh uh
nelson opens uh with uh uh e4
we have knight to f6 going for
alejandra's defense with the ship the c4
uh this is the krejcik variation of the
alien and it's a very very
uh tricky line if you don't know it with
black but it's not good for white if
black knows what black's doing
the idea is if you capture the pawn then
white can go for this bishop captures an
f7 king captures queen h5 check
and you're gonna win back material for
example king g8 you're gonna go queen d5
check
and now after the uh check is blocked
you're going to win back your piece
but black gets really a lot of
development for this for example d5
queen e3 c5
and so on but if you're playing a three
plus zero blitz game
and you're not sure about this then
maybe you avoid it like uh
pellegros did in this game so instead we
have d6
uh knight to c3 and now g6 so preparing
to find it to the dark square bishop
uh we have d4 grabbing the center and
now bishop to g7
uh we have f3 uh strengthening the
center and now preparing the force g4 h4
h5 and so on uh the classical setup when
black goes for this fiance set up in the
kingside castle uh we have castle's king
side and now
bishop to e3 knight to c6 now putting
more pressure on the center continuing
development and the queen to d2 now
we have e5 and now d5 closing the center
as
white wants to attack on the king side
so usually it's very principle
if you're attacking on the king side you
usually want the center and the queen
side to remain closed so black doesn't
get
a lot of counter play so knights to e7
and now bishop to h6 another standard
move
in positions like these you want to
trade off black's dark square bishop as
this is
this is just a monster often referred to
uh well so
in sicilian defense is often referred to
as the dragon but i call it
the dragon pretty much uh in all uh well
uh
lines where it's iffy and cathode so
here knight the e8
uh adding another defender here but uh
mostly making room for this pawn to be
pushed to f5 with bishop captures king
captures
and knight g to e2 now uh we have h6
with black and now queen side castle so
white says
all right the century is closed i'm
going to castle queenside and now i'm
going to start pushing my pawns on the
king
side and here we have f5 and this is a
bit of a well uh i don't know how to
call it but
usually when your opponent castles on
the other side of the board you can see
the black castle kingside white castle
queen side
usually you want to attack uh where your
opponent has castle so maybe here's
something like a6 and b5 we already have
a nice
bishop on c4 to attack so maybe we can
get b5 into its tempo b4 in which tempo
and so on
but okay here black decided to go with
f5 and this only
uh well plays right into white's plan so
here
h4 uh continuing with the pawn pushing
and here
f4 black closes the uh tries to close
the king side rider but it doesn't
really work here
rook d to g1 and now knight to f6
and now g3 and this g3 is a very
important move you do not want to play
g4
if you play g4 then black can just move
the knight and you're not
getting anywhere if you push g5 h5 or if
you push h5 g5
uh doesn't really matter i mean black
will close the position and good luck
attacking this uh well this king on g7
now
uh with this pawn structure like this
look at this this is uh
nothing is getting through this this is
uh this is impenetrable
so instead after knight to f6 of course
white went for g3
now you want to open up the g file uh we
have knight
to h5 now putting pressure uh on the
point but also if captures you can
capture with the knight
but here white doesn't open up the g
file now white pushes g4 but now it
works because after knight
goes back to f6 you will have a dual
target so knight f6
with g5 now attacking the knight end of
the pawn
captures captures and now knight to h5
and here well you could play some
prophylactic ideas like king to b1 white
says nope we are now
uh going through and that happens with
rook
captures on h5 while objectively maybe
not
the greatest idea for a three minute
blizz game it
definitely uh hurts a lot so g
captures on h5 and now rook to h1 where
we want to open up the h file now
uh rook the h8 defending and now we
attack further and happily sacrifice
more pieces so knight captures on f4
and what do you do here well you kind of
have to capture it that knight is now a
monster here
so we have e captures on f4 and now
queen to d4
with check kink the g8 and now we've
sacrificed a lot but we still don't have
a lot to show for it so we have to
continue uh pushing uh
everything forward so just e5 so what do
you do here
capturing would be a bit too dangerous
because then just the
d6 check and you're not really gonna
get anything here if king f8 just queen
captures on e5
uh now you're threatening captures uh
the rook is being threatened so
after knight g6 defending the rook
getting the knight out of the way we can
play queen d5 threat and checkmate
and while black can defend this with
perfect play we always have to remember
it's a three plus zero game
it would be very very hard to defend
this with black so instead after e5 we
have knight to f5 now attacking the
queen
queen captures on f4 and now now black
played everything perfectly up to this
point
and now black needs to continue doing so
but that's often
uh very hard because it's easy to attack
like there's a saying it's easy to
attack it's very hard to defend
uh because uh when attacking you
generally have the idea of what you're
doing when you're defending not not
really and here
and the only defense for black is
captures and that's
something you almost never want to do
when defending you want to develop you
want to get your pieces into the game
the point is after queen captures queen
here and now it's
you basically force a queen trade
because there's no good square for the
white queen the
you can't really go here knight g3 forks
the rook and the queen
here this is taken by the knight so you
would have to go back then queen f4
check king moves and then we're gonna
block this pawn then develop the bishop
then bring the rook into the game
and our position is just great however
here queen to f8 was played
but now white gets one very important
tempo that he immediately plays and that
is
knight to e4 the f6 square is uh well
uh up for for grabs so to say and
there's not much black can do about it
here we have king to g7
king to f7 might be a bit more resilient
because then if
uh sorry uh if king to f7 maybe we can
e6 and king to e7 but it would still be
very very difficult to play this so
instead king to g7 was played
but now knight the uh knight to f6
now the knight is on an excellent square
here king to g6 now
if e6 comes the knight will lose
protection so the king here serves as a
protector of the knight but that's not
really
uh uh you know very very comforting as
this bishop is coming to d3 i mean we
all know that
so here e6 blocking this dark square
bishop and look at this now black's
rook is doing nothing this rook is doing
nothing the bishop is doing nothing
queen i mean okay queen is uh is here
but not really doing all that much
what the piece that's doing the most
work here in this position in black's
camp is actually the king and g6
so here knight the e7 getting the knight
out of the way as we know bishop to d3
is coming
and this is exactly what white plays
bishop to d3 check
king to g7 and now uh you could uh you
know rush through this by force for
example
rook captures on h5 rook captures knight
captures with check and this
will now be winning for example king the
g8 just bishop to h7 check
and once the the bishop is captured we
can win the queen and then easily win
the game however
black chooses white chooses a more of a
stylish way to end the game and plays
queen to d
for now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and notice that
there is no square available to the
black king all of these squares are
taken by the pawn by the bishop by the
other pawn
by the knight and well it's just a very
unpleasant position to be in
uh there's no good move here uh black
played c5 sort of trying to say okay if
you move the knight i'm going to capture
your queen
but white doesn't doesn't really care
because now white has a forced
check made in six and it's a really a
wonderful one
so feel free to pause the video here and
finish this never green game
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on going for the
uh
most forcing of lines and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
of course it is night captures on h5 uh
night the e8
check also works it also serves as a
double check from the knight and from
the queen
but it takes a few more moves to end it
here with uh knight captures on h5
is just instant death uh the king has no
squares and it's
it's double check we always have to
remember that saying
uh in uh i always i always forget forget
it
but even the the bravest king flees in
the face of a double check or something
like that
uh but yeah king to g8 only move and now
comes the move
you all saw when you played knight stage
5 check and that of course is
queen captures an h8 we're gonna check
this out immediately in slow motion
so let's just go after that queen
captures an h8 only move for black is to
capture the queen and now of course
knight back to f6 with check and here
there are no moves you could play king
to g7 and get
checkmated right away or you could play
what was played in the game and that is
queen to h6
uh give up the queen just to prolong the
game for a few more moves
rook captures king g7 rook h7 check king
f8
this is all forced and now rook to f7 is
checkmate as the knight covers g8 and
e8 both so really really impressive game
by
uh by uh national master nelson lopez uh
really uh you know uh really a lot of
attacking like
like we all enjoy it and uh well it was
just a wonderful
okay maybe not the most uh correct of
ideas but for a three-minute blitz game
you know
it's just what we what we want and what
we enjoy and what
we should always go for so really really
awesome game
and one other thing i wanted to mention
if you're ever in a position like this
when
uh where your opponent already reaches a
position like this don't play queen to
h6
it just ruins the beauty of the game uh
always play something like this and
allow a checkmate like this
i mean you you will lose in it doesn't
really matter if you're losing three
moves or
in one move uh but the the final
position is much much nicer if there's
still a queen on the board so it doesn't
matter if you win the game or lose the
game
you should always uh allow your opponent
to to create
a a position like this as well even
though
it means losing the game i know losing
is hard but uh
you will feel much better if you allow
uh such a position to happen just
something to consider maybe in the
future
uh while you're you know destroying
everyone in your own online games
uh so yeah uh once again uh don't forget
i will put a link in the description
below first link will be
uh the tournament arena unleashes that
will be today i will be streaming it so
you know do join and help us out we need
a lot of
a lot of players winning a lot of points
and there will
of course will be a chance for you for
your own game to be showcased i'm not
going to be playing i'm just going to be
enjoying the chat and showcasing your
game so we can show as many of your
games as possible
the tournament lasts two hours so i
imagine we'll get um
quite a lot of opportunities to show uh
more more of your games
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed this really a wonderful
wonderful game uh i would like to thank
daniel martin uh thomas dyson
steven dennis seifert and jerry draver
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day